S
CONVERSATIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND JOINING ME NOW FOR MORE
REACTION, AMERICA FIRST LEGAL
FOUNDER STEPHEN MILLER ALONG
WITH TENNESSEE SENATOR MARSHA
BLACKBURN.
ALL RIGHT, I WILL GO TO USE
SENATOR BLACKBURN.
I MEAN, WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON
WHAT THEY ARE SAYING ABOUT
AMERICA AS A RESULT OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, ALLEGED MIXED
MESSAGES, WHICH I REALLY DON'T
THINK ARE MIXED.
I THINK THEY ARE REALLY CLEAR.
COME ON IN AND MAKE YOURSELF AT
HOME.
>> YOU ARE EXACTLY RIGHT.
THAT IS THE MIXED MESSAGE.
AND FOR HER TO GO AND SAY WELL,
THE BORDER IS CLOSED, THEY DON'T
BELIEVE THAT.
BECAUSE THEY ARE SEEING PEOPLE
LEAVE.
AND AS YOU ARE HEARING FROM THE
GUATEMALA PRESIDENT, THEY DON'T
WANT THE CARTELS AND THE
COMMUNIST CHINESE IN THEIR
COUNTRY.
THEY WANT US TO SHOW SOME
RESPECT FOR THEM AND TO WORK
WITH THEM ON TRADE.
IT LETS PEOPLE KNOW THAT OUR
BORDER IS CLOSED, BECAUSE IT
ACTUALLY IS CLOSED.
AND FOR VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS TO
GO TO GUATEMALA AND SAY WHAT SHE
SAID WITHOUT HAVING FIRST GONE
TO THE BORDER AND TALK TO THE
BORDER PATROL AND HAVING TALKED
TO PEOPLE, TALK TO THOSE THAT
ARE WORKING WITH PEOPLE COMING
IN, TALKING TO THE LOCAL
SHERIFFS, TALKING TO THE LOCALS,
THEY WILL TELL YOU THREE THINGS.
WE NEED A WALL, WE NEED BETTER
TECHNOLOGY, AND WE NEED MORE
BOOTS ON THE GROUND.
IT IS THE SAME THING THEY'VE
BEEN ASKING FOR PRESIDENT JUMP
GAVE IT TO THEM AND SINCE
JOE BIDEN TOOK OFFICE, WE'VE HAD
THE BORDER PATROL APPREHENDED
OVER A HALF MILLION PEOPLE,
180,000 LAST MONTH.
AND THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE THE GOD
A WAYS.
SO OF COURSE YOU HAVE TO SECURE
OUR BORDER AND SHE OUGHT TO BE
THERE FIRST.
>> Jeanine: OBVIOUSLY
STEPHEN MILLER -- HE WERE
INTIMATELY INVOLVED IN
EVERYTHING THAT WAS GOING ON AT
THE WHITE HOUSE.
IT'S GOT TO BE FRUSTRATING FOR
YOU, BUT IN ADDITION TO THE
FRUSTRATION, TO SEE SO MUCH OF
WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP DID BEING
LITERALLY DISMANTLED.
HE REALIZED THAT THIS IS GOING
TO BE A TREMENDOUS BURDEN ON THE
AMERICAN TAXPAYER.
WHAT IS YOUR ORGANIZATION, THE
FIRST LEGAL FOUNDATION, DOING
ABOUT THIS, IF ANYTHING?
>> WE ARE RIGHT NOW INVOLVED AS
THE OUTSIDE COUNSEL FOR THE
STATE OF TEXAS IN A LAWSUIT
AGAINST THE ILLEGAL CATCH AND
RELEASE POLICIES HAPPENING IN
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER AND WE ARE
ALSO WORKING WITH STATES
INCLUDING LOUISIANA WITH WHOM
ARE ALSO PART OF THEIR LEGAL
TEAM SUING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION OVER THERE
IMMORAL, ILLEGAL, AND
UNCONSTITUTIONAL POLICY
FUNCTIONALLY ABOLISHING EYES AND
SHUTTING DOWN INTERIOR
ENFORCEMENT AND FREEING
CRIMINALS AND MASKS.
LET ME BREAK THIS DOWN IN A VERY
FUNDAMENTAL WAY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOUGHT
HEROICALLY AS NO ONE EVER HAD
BEFORE FOR AMERICAN CITIZENS.
HE HAD REMAINED IN MEXICO, HE
HAD AGREEMENTS THAT ENDED ASYLUM
FRAUD FROM CENTRAL AMERICA
CATEGORICALLY.
TO SHUT IT DOWN COMPLETELY.
HE SECURED THIS BORDER AS NO ONE
EVER HAD BEFORE.
THE NEW TEAM CAME IN AND THEY
WORKED NIGHT AND DAY TO SHRED
OUR BORDER SECURITY.
INNOCENT AMERICANS ARE BEING
KILLED AS A RESULT OF THE DRUGS
POURING ACROSS OUR BORDER.
MS-13 GAME MEMBERS ARE COMING IN
AT ON A COMPANY MINORS.
THE SCHOOLS ARE BEING
OVERWHELMED, THE HOSPITALS ARE
BEING ANTEDATED.
IT'S A MORAL STAIN ON THE
CONSCIOUS OF OUR NATION.
AND MY GROUP IS FIGHTING IN
COURT AND WE ARE FIGHTING TO
RESTORE AT THE AND NECESSARY
POLICIES THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
PUT INTO PLACE TO SAFEGUARD THE
SOVEREIGNTY AND THE SECURITY OF
THIS BLESSED NATION.
>> Jeanine: STEPHEN, THE ISSUE
OF GOVERNOR ABBOTT SAYING THAT
HE'S GOING TO TAKE PART OF THE
MILLION DOLLARS THAT HE'S
ALLOCATED FOR SECURITY TO
REBUILD OR TO CONTINUE BUILDING
THE WALL ON THE TEXAS BORDER --
ARE THEY GOING TO TRY TO STOP
THAT THE WAY THEY TRIED TO STOP
THE PRESIDENT FROM EVEN BUILDING
THE WALL?
>> I'M SURE THEY ARE, I'M SURE
THEY'RE GOING TO MAKE IT
EXTRAORDINARILY DIFFICULT AND HE
WHERE THEY CAN KNOW THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION STOP THE WALL
CONSTRUCTION THAT WAS ALREADY
FUNDED, THAT WAS ALREADY
APPROPRIATED.
THAT WAS OUTRAGEOUS.
THAT ALONE CONTRIBUTED TO THE
180,000 PEOPLE WHO CROSSED HER
BORDER LAST MONTH.
I'LL MAKE ONE MORE POINT THAT IS
VERY IMPORTANT.
THE VICE PRESIDENT KEEPS TALKING
ABOUT ROOT CAUSES, ROOT CAUSES,
ROOT CAUSES.
I'VE GOT NEWS FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE APPEAR THIS IS A JUST A
PROBLEM OF THREE COUNTRIES
COMING TO OUR BORDER.
YOU HAVE 160 PLUS COUNTRIES
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO?
WERE GOING TO REPAIR THE ENTIRE
PLANET?
WERE GOING TO REBUILD EVERY
COUNTRY ON EARTH?
IT'S NOT POSSIBLE, IT'S NOT
DOABLE, IT IS A LIE.
SHE IS LYING TO YOU.
>> AND THE ROOT CAUSE --
>> Jeanine: WELL, IT IS A
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION POLICY.
BUT IN ADDITION TO THAT, IF SHE
EVER GETS TO THE BOTTOM OF THE
ROOT CAUSE, WHY IS SHE SO AFRAID
TO GO TO THE BORDER?
CAN YOU TELL THE VIEWERS WHY SHE
DOESN'T WANT TO GO?
>> I THINK SHE'S AFRAID TO GO TO
THE BORDER BECAUSE WHAT IS SHE
GOING TO DO?
IS SHE GOING TO WELCOME THOSE
THAT ARE ILLEGALLY COMING OR IS
SHE GOING TO SAY, THIS IS OUR
PROBLEM, WE HAVE MADE THIS MESS,
OUR COMMUNITIES WANT THEIR
COMMUNITIES BACK, OUR RANGERS
WANT THEIR RANCHES BACK.
PEOPLE WANT TO SEE THIS BORDER
SECURE.
PEOPLE ON THAT PORTER WILL TELL
YOU THIS.
IF YOU PUT PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
MIGRANT PROTECTION PROTOCOLS
BACK IN PLACE, WHICH I HAVE
LEGISLATION TO DO THAT, THAT HAS
THAT REMAIN IN MEXICO POLICY
THAT SAVED OUR COUNTRY.
AND THAT WAY THE BORDER CONTROL
CONTENT TO THE BORDER.
RATHER THAN HAVING TO DEAL WITH
APPREHENDING 180,000 INDIVIDUALS
IN A MONTH.
>> SUCH AN IMPORTANT POINT THE
SENATOR JUST MADE.
THEY ARE A THREAT TO OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY AND EVERYONE
NEEDS TO BE TALKING ABOUT THIS